Let us take a look again
at our remove html markup function.
Here I'm going back to the earlier version,
which is sort of fixed.
Now let's take a look at this condition up here.
We want to know where the core value
could possibly have come from
To do so, we follow the data dependencies.
What are the statements that this statement
is data dependent upon?
To do so, we will look at the places
where quote would be written.
And which also would be executed
before this statement will be executed.
For instance, this statement would be data
dependent on that earlier statement.
Because here quote is being written,
and here quote is being read.
Therefore, the statement A up here sets the state
that B later on keeps on processing.
If you want to understand how B behaves,
we follow the data dependencies to A
and find that this is one of the statements
that sets the state that B depends upon.
Now for a quiz.
Which are the other statements that B data depends upon?
Is this for C in S,
is this elf of C equals the greater sign and not quote,
is this quote equals not quote,
or is this out equals out plus C?
Check all that apply.